it very very often happens in fact it
happens almost enemy every single given
tournament a low rate of the player
let's say in this case yourself are
playing against a high rated player in
this case let's say myself and you would
like to make a draw and there's a rating
gap between you and your playing the
black pieces okay never make a draw no
but you would like to make a draw let's
say it's the last round and the draw
helps you win your tournament prize and
you would be very very satisfied with a
draw and yet you're facing this higher
rated player and you know it's you know
it's going to be a very difficult game
for yourself and so it's incumbent upon
you as players as tournament players is
as passion passionate chess players to
create what I call a sweet secret weapon
this is your secret opening weapon man
and you need this and you don't trot it
out every day oh no no no no you kind of
keep it you know well hidden and you use
it in those really really big moments
when you when you need it and I'll tell
you a story that I really like to to
explain what I'm going to show you in
terms of developing and how to develop a
secret opening defense if weapon is in
the good old days of the Soviet Union
the Soviet Union Chess Federation was
one of the most well supported sports in
Soviet Union and the Soviet Union had
world champions just about every type of
sport you can imagine from ice skating
to weightlifting to boxing you name it
the Soviet Union had a lot of the world
champions in many different disciplines
but chess by and large gotta
and share of the sporting budget of the
Soviet Union and chess was very very
strongly supported throughout the Soviet
Union so much so that Soviet Union
championships the men's Championships
and the women's championships would
often be held together at you know the
five-star hotels of Soviet Union at the
time and very very good playing
conditions often times in a very
beautiful ballet opera house type of
setting and the kitchen was really good
the food was really good the players
were really well treated and these two
events the Soviet ladies championship
and the Soviet championship would be
held concurrently together and the
Soviet players were really kind of
treated as celebrities and famous stars
so they literally had their own
restaurant that was secluded in side the
hotel and Boris Spassky the World Chess
Champion was sitting at his table with
his trainer chess grandmaster Tolu Sh
and totally she was one of those
trainers and those Soviet guys who were
heavy and very very very deliberative
type of person and they're having their
dinner together and one of the ladies of
the Soviet Championship has joined them
and she's taken her purse and she
literally swings it around in the air
and throws it on the floor you know and
orders of vodka and needless to say she
had lost that round that day in to make
matters worse the next day meaning
tomorrow she was going to play one of
her key competitors and she was now
facing the black pieces and she was in
great distress this lady and Tolu began
by saying something along the lines of
Victoria tomorrow your opponent will
play e4
you must play e5 is deep heavy sigh
breathing she will play Knight f3
you will play knight c6 your opponent
she will play Bishop c4 and this
continues the same kind of methodical
deep breathing explanation of the moves
you will play Knight d4 she will play
Knight takes e5 you will play Queen g5
she will play Knight takes f7 you will
play Queen takes g2 she will play rook
f1 you will play Queen takes e4 check
she will play Bishop e2 and you will
play Knight f3 check makes the woman
spirits were raised the next day same
setting same situation Spassky and
toller's you're having dinner this woman
walks proudly into the room like a
cockatoo you know just like very proud
comes to Tolo should takes his cheeks
like this
these plants a big kiss on his mouth and
a wound you're a genius
today I have won brilliantly just as you
said and she turned and looked with at
world champion Boris Spassky with
absolute contempt and said ha world
champion
with such a trainer I could be world
champion so look at that a nice secret
secret secret weapon huh
obviously 92 is not that great of move
and that's not what we're about to talk
about but what I am about to talk about
is developing a secret weapon you're
playing against a high rated player
you're black you're your worst fear is
about to come true
they're going to play efore and
immediate and instant pressure is coming
on your shoulders and all you need is a
draw to win your prize and to do
whatever success in the tournament that
you would like well it's very
interesting when you're faced in this
psychological situation you need to make
a draw and so you've got to develop a
surprise weapon that will achieve your
aim and one of the things that you can
do and should do with the black pieces
against a higher rated player is to be
aggressive to be aggressive don't curl
up into some wonderfully passive ball
and say I'm going to put my fortress and
you you try to storm me because that's
exactly what the stronger player would
like is to have a no-risk
type of situation where he or she is
trying to defeat you from a superior
position against efore there are only
two types of Defense's one you attack
efore the second type of defense you
leave it alone we're going to look at
the first type of defense with by
through a surprise
so e5 Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop oops
now I wasn't the move I wanted oh that
was because I was playing showing the
game of tol
/ yeah Bishop b5 okay so a six Bishop a4
so so far your opponent your higher
rated opponent is very happy he you've
chosen a defense that has tens of
thousands of whatever numbers of chess
grandmaster games and theory has
approved that white by and large is
going to have an advantage of positional
advantage of some type and for quite a
long while and he your higher rated
opponent is going to nurse that
positional advantage and wait for you to
crack and find a bad move and that will
be the end of the game so you go you
continue in just normal everyday style
Knight f6 castles and this is why I say
we're going to look at the first type of
Defense's to 1.e4 where you capture the
pawn on e4 or you attack and capture the
pawn on e4 now had you played for
example your you were preparing
assistant with Bishop e7 this would be
the normal and most well trodden path of
the ruie Lopez Bishop e7 but instead
your secret weapon is Knight takes e4
well again one of the things I strongly
recommend when you're developing your
secret weapon your secret drawing weapon
is to be as aggressive and as combative
as possible and there's nothing more
aggressive or combative in that
particular position then capturing the
pawn on e4
well theory has long established for
many many years now that the actual only
way for white to get an opening
advantage is to continue by the Moody
for for example if white were to
continue with another move such as for
example will be one or perhaps even
Queenie too
this simply is not a very good idea for
white because after 95 you're attacking
this Bishop on a four and after move for
example like Bishop c6 D takes c6 Knight
takes e5 Bishop e7 d4 not only can black
face the future with confidence he
simply better in the position he has the
two bishops and following the move
castle he simply has a superior position
so in a in essence what I'm saying is
after the move Knight takes e4 there is
one and only one move in this position
that doesn't give white the worse gain
and that is d4 which meets our criteria
of being very very forceful we want
sharp attacking moves now at this moment
we have what we call the open Spanish
and the very standard move for black is
to play the move B 7 B 5 Bishop b3 D 5 D
takes e5 Bishop e6 these are literally
the open the opening moves of the open
Spanish a lot of moves go from here
practitioners of the open Spanish
include world chess champion Viswanathan
Dan on this she has had the open Spanish
in his repertoire most of his career
former world champion vasily smyslov
championed the black side of the open
spanish many many time challenger to the
world champion Viktor Korchnoi played
the open Spanish and one of my
colleagues grandmaster archer Yusupov in
many of his candidate
matches he too played this position the
black side of the open Spanish and again
to repeat myself b5 this should be 3d 5
are the standard looms well one of the
criterias that our secret weapon has to
include is not the main main lines but
rather a side variation the side
variation that we hope that our higher
rated opponent may not be familiar with
so we're looking for something good and
solid that simultaneously we're looking
for something that's very aggressive
that's very forcing and that's a bit of
a sideline and so in this position what
I'd like to suggest to you and well as I
remind myself this is what this was one
of my secret secret weapons ok you know
like when my opponents weren't weren't
waiting so what I would do is I take
upon hey man I'm two pawns up this is it
this is what I would call an
in-your-face kind of move I'm two pawns
up and I'm simply challenging you my
higher-rated ponent to prove yourself if
you allow me I will play Bishop e7 and
castles and a man on two pawns up so
I'll turn to the to the audience and say
if you had this position as white what
move would you play any suggestions
Julian rook e1 does anybody have any
other suggestion beside rook e1 rook e1
is simply the most obvious human move
and most people would play it rook e1
will be our main line I just want to put
Queen e2 on the board for a moment
to explain why Queenie to would be bad
after Queenie to Queenie seven rookie
one night see 695 I beg your pardon if
you go back with Queen to d1 well I'll
play 96 and I'll be very very happy I'm
still two pawns up and after for example
a move like c3 I'll play d3 I'll not
allow you to capture the pawn on d4
after for example Queen takes d3 I'll
play Queen d6 if you like to trade
Queens I'd be most happy and if you
don't trade Queens my next move will be
Bishop e7 castles I'll be a pawn up and
I'll be doing extremely well thank you
very much for asking so when we go back
to this position our main move is rook
e1 see that's the new main line right
okay great rook e1 excellent move
congratulations your are threatening to
win my night because my knight of course
is pinned to my king at this moment you
have to understand the psychological
things that are happening in our
imagined battle what's going on is our
high rated opponent understands he's
playing a lower rated opponent and he's
feeling really good because the lower
head opponent has just messed up he's
got himself in a pin and at this point
we can expect our high rated later
higher rated opponent be looking at his
watch and wondering if he has time for
the game on TV yeah right okay we play
the obvious d7 d5 which of course
protects the knight on e4 and once again
if we're allowed to play moves like
Bishop e7 castles we're going to be very
happy suggestion for white what should
white now do to continue the game
Knight takes d4 everybody and his
brother would play the move Knight takes
d4 and it's so logical the knight
captures the pawn on d4 it attacks the
knight on c6 thanks to this bishop on a4
let's put that move on the board I think
everybody would play the move Knight
takes d4 without too much thought
because in fact there's a double threat
threat number one once again includes
Knight takes c6 takes on c6 Bishop takes
c6 take the rook or take the pawn so
that's threat number one threat number
two includes the move f2 f3 the knight
on e4 is a pin it's it's clear that you
the weaker player have made an egregious
error and you're going down you're going
down real real fast well great and again
I congratulate the stronger player and I
simply play the move Bishop d6 and I say
your turn
so at this moment the stronger player
starts to have this kind of a strange
chill a feeling like like my duffer
opponent my weaker opponent is putting
up some resistance because he sees that
after the much intended Knight takes c6
one ramification is he has to think
about Bishop takes h2 check and in case
of King takes h2 Queen h4 so in fact
this idea of Bishop takes h2 check King
takes h2 check Queen h4 is very
concerning because it also works against
f2 f3 what we are trying to achieve with
our secret weapon is a draw so a move
like f2 f3 Bishop takes h2 check
in trying to make perpetual checks is
basically what's going on in our minds
and again our high rated player is kind
of mystified and concerned I mean he
just you know he's played all the
standard moves and you've played the
surprising move e5 takes d4 instead of
going for b5 Bishop d3 d5 as mentioned
earlier you've come up with a little
twist and at the moment black is upon a
head
annie has a very concrete idea of making
a perpetual check so I'd like to turn it
over to the audience and imagine that
you had the white pieces what would you
do with white yes Julian rook takes e4
and that's very very nice rook takes e4
D takes e4 followed by yeah okay well
unfortunately you're faster than I was
in terms of pointing out the problem
there is Bishop takes h2 King takes h2
Queen takes d1 and instead of getting
our coveted draw we're going to get a
win
oops so rook takes e4 a nice plan
tactically Julian is showing his gifted
his gifts but a small tiny detail it
didn't work okay but that was good that
kind of you know that that maybe our
opponent considered rook takes e4 D
takes e4 Knight takes c6 and then
suddenly saw the line that you just
suggested and said oh geez
now he's a little bit scared like okay
so again Julian let's try again
all right very good okay this will be
our main line Knight takes c6 because in
fact there really isn't much else for
white to do other than Knight takes c6
and of course it's the continuation of
his whole strategy up to now and it's
very clear if I play the move b7 take c6
then after Bishop takes c6 check
followed by Bishop takes d5 my positions
crap I can't play like this therefore
I'm going to play Bishop takes h2 check
now I'm dreaming I really am I'm truly
dreaming that you will play King takes
h2 I will play Queen h4 check you will
play King g1 and I'll just make my
perpetual check and hey my secret weapon
it came into fruition so we're going to
reject the move King takes h2 as a very
big success for ourselves and instead
we're going to try King f1 thank you
okay so King f1 so at this moment let's
take a material count 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4
5 6 7
I'm two pawns up whoops
1 2 3 4 minor pieces 1 2 3 minor pieces
I'm a piece down arrow very bad very
very bad but at the same time we don't
give up we continue our our line of play
we understand I can't take the knight
after King h1 and after King f1 I have
to play the move and I do apologize
Queen h4 probably because of your Queen
f3 so I play Queen h4 with the direct
idea of taking the pawn on f2 and now
what what would you play if you were
white
I think from the human point of view
most people would play the move Bishop
III does that appear normal to
yourselves
this is actually my main line Bishop III
I don't know I'll show you what my main
- my main line is Bishop to e3 and now
the very surprising move castles okay so
essentially what I'm saying is I have
two pawns for the piece my king is safe
but I also I have an initiative I'm
expecting that you will try the move
Knight d4 I will play the move Bishop to
g4 and I'm expecting that you will play
the move Knight f3 let me just make sure
I'm up to date on my analysis that's
right so far so good and I will play the
move Queen h5 okay so my idea is first
of all I have two pawns for the piece
great my queen protects the pawn on d5
so there's no Queen takes d5 secondly
your extra piece is this Bishop on a4
well but that Bishop on a4 for example
after move like c7 c6 is not what we're
going to describe is a very effective
extra piece in the meanwhile I'm a play
moves like Bishop on h2 to d6 with the
idea of Queen h1 check and you're going
to experience a lot of unpleasant
sensations after this move in fact at
this exact moment my best move for you
and you're not going to like this one
single bit is that
after night bd2 I consider this your
best move I don't see a better move than
night bd2 and after Bishop e5 I consider
this position as simply much better for
black I have two threats in the position
my first threat that should scare the
bejesus out of you is Queen h1 check and
my second threat is that I want to play
the move Bishop takes b2 followed by the
move Knight c3 and you're not happy your
queen will be trapped so we're going to
go back and we're going to save this
whole variation socks for white it just
simply is a bad variation we're going to
go back back back back to this moment
yeah well we're going to come back and
go forwards a bit so we can understand
where we came from so in this position
everybody and his brother plays b5
Bishop d3 d5 takes Bishop e6 and we're
in the in the open Spanish I'm
suggesting as a secret weapon takes
which looks extraordinary risky and
quite frankly bad for the second player
and then rook e1 the very human move d5
protecting the night the very human move
Knight takes d4 Bishop d6 we're looking
at our main line as Knight takes c6
Bishop takes h2 King King f1 Queen h4
and instead of the move Bishop e3 where
we're going to suggest another move for
white here sorry at this point also
again
keep in mind the psychological situation
that our opponent is going through you
know he's playing this much weaker
player yourself much lower rated player
I should say he's expecting you to curl
up and die and well it's very obviously
you're not curling up and dying you're
putting up some serious scare tactics in
white and after sorry Queen h4 we're
thinking that the best move for white is
Knight d4 check Knight d4 check with
ideas of ideas of immediately well you
got to protect the square F 2 attacking
with Knight f3
so 94 check pardon me b5 b5 I think is
d5 Bishop e3 Bishop g4 and once more
sorry I put it on this board b5 oops
asking Bishop e3 Bishop g4 and black is
getting what he wants okay you can put
this game and this whole analysis in
your engines and I think it's going to
really freak you out when you discover
that white simply stands worse that
white is in trouble when he when White
has literally done nothing wrong that he
has in fact followed
in normal play and again why can do
other things is this the moment where
you wanted to play the move h3 instead
of capturing this knight on c6 the
gentleman has suggested well what about
simply a move like h2 h3 let me go back
here I don't think I have that in my
whatchamacallit analysis hmm okay I
don't have oh well I think well let's
just continue as if you had played
Knight to c6 and let's just continue
with the move Queen h4 anyway with very
direct idea of capturing this pawn on f2
so after a move like Queen h4 which I
think makes a great deal of sense hmm
Queen h4 I'm supposing Bishop e3 I'm not
really too sure right now this is a very
very standard kind of what you call it
tactic that occurs in a line I think
it's called the Janowski variation the
Janowski gambit and you should become
very familiar with this tactical idea if
we go back to this for a moment in this
position it goes like f5 Knight c3
--tags --tags d5 Knight takes pawn takes
Queen oops
Queen here OS what about a white mobile
Queen Queen here so the idea here is
you're
you're you have a double attack you want
to take you want to take Queen e2 and
then in this position one of the things
that black can do is go like knight c6
d4 Queen takes rook f1 and then the idea
is after a6 Bishop here to play the move
Bishop d7 and this is a very important
tactic that occurs in many variations
where there's a Bishop b5 95 Knight
takes c6 so how does that how does this
apply to the line that we were looking
at well if we go back and we come up
with this move h3 Queen h4 rook takes
pawn takes Knight takes we're suddenly
see well obviously it's quite clear we
cannot take this Knight but we have this
very nice move Bishop d7 which we're
going to borrow from the Janowski gambit
for a moment and what the idea here is
is at one time our Black Knight was
pinned to our King suddenly this white
knight is pinned to this white Bishop on
a4 and there's nothing that but white is
going to be able to do to save the piece
in other words black is going to win
back his piece and obviously being an
exchange ahead at the moment he's going
to do it with interest okay so let's go
back for a moment to this position and
I'm going to give you what I think is
the main line and it's wild rook e1 d5
Knight takes d4 I think these are the
best moves for white I think Knight
takes c6 is the best move for white and
I think after Bishop takes h2 White has
one and only one move to try to gain
an advantage in other words so far white
has played the very best moves according
to our analysis the very best move is in
my opinion King h1
this will be our new main variation king
h1 and now we play the obvious Queen h4
and it looks it looks a little bit scary
for white in fact I would be terrified
if I was white I'd be terrified that the
bishop is going to come back with check
and I'm going to end up being made it
check mated well white can pull off a
miracle
y can play rook takes e4 check pawn
takes e4 Queen d8 check these are in my
opinion the very very best moves for
white Queen takes d8 Knight takes dhx
King takes d8 King takes h2 in other
words we've reached the end of the line
and we have to sum things up I think
white is slightly slightly better in
this ending essentially he has two
pieces for a rook but black also has two
pawns one two three four five six seven
one two three four five so two pieces
for a rook and two pawns black has what
you might say a slight edge in the
material count but in truth after King
takes h2 f5 I think no I think Bishop
Bishop e6 I've met Bishop e6 new Lane
line Bishop here fi I had I had analyzed
to this position and I gave white a
slight at
so this was my secret weapon
that if white plays absolutely
absolutely perfect we get an endgame
that I could play and you probably I'm
going to give white a slight edge but
it's not a certainty and it's a very
interesting and complex position but
look how many bullets white had dodged
right
at some moment our opponent like to say
hey I'm just getting out of this that's
not going to allow you your virtual jack
I don't want to deal with you anymore so
in this position first of all the one
and only move for white to give white an
advantage is d4 we take rook e1 d5
Knight takes d4 Bishop d6 there are
moves like h3 and other moves but
essentially Knight takes c6 is the most
consequent Bishop takes H to check our
opponent can bail out and allow the
perpetual King takes Queen check King
back Queen takes and the perpetual
between h4 + f2 right away he could play
a poor move which was King f1 after king
f1 I assure you that after Queen h4
black stands better and again I urge you
to put this in your chess engines and
confirm because it's quite a surprise
and the best move can you imagine in a
tournament game your opponent playing
the move King h1 and after Queen h4
finding all of these moves to getting
what might be a slight advantage in the
ending a very very complex line but this
is basically what gunslingers in the Old
West they had their fast draw that was
how they survived well in chess
competitions your fast draw has to be
your secret weapon your chess opening
novelty where you come with a big
surprise and this is an example
of just that and how you go about making
the big surprise is you follow a
mainline you find a sudden you find a
certain sidetrack and you catch your
opponent with your preparation